buenas tardes realmente no la cambie
pero claramente son buenas noticias
porque la efectividad es más alta de lo
que esperábamos obviamente son noticias
preliminares tenemos que esperar a que
se publiquen los datos científicos pero
en general esto nos da una buena luz de
lo que podría ser la efectividad no sólo
de esta vacuna sino de las otras vacunas
que vienen por las otras farmacéuticas
doctor que hace falta en el proceso para
que podamos decir que la vacuna es
completamente efectiva
bueno la fase 3 de no solo este estudio
de países sino de las otras vacunas se
tiene que terminar esto es cuando
reclutan a todas las personas les hayan
dado las dos dosis y hayan pasado al
menos dos meses después de la segunda
dosis para asegurarse de que la vacuna
no sólo es efectiva sino segura y una
vez tengamos esos datos la fd a mirar a
luz las investigaciones seguramente dará
una autorización preliminar para que
esta vacuna se empiece a aplicar en eeuu
y posteriormente en los meses siguientes
en el 2021 esperemos que haya muchas más
dosis disponibles a nivel mundial en
latinoamérica